you can't nuke a network how would you
nuke Bitcoin you inward Army
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from Magic
we're recording this uh a week or so
before the the biggest elections of our
lives and the government of the United
States of America at least here and uh
in California it's a late evening a week
or so before the election I'm talking
today to a renowned individual thinker
an engineer a Creator sort of a
philosopher a guru to many around the
world maybe millions and that's biology
certain of us and Dr biology and we uh
we I think we barely may have overlapped
I was at Stanford uh you were there for
a very long time maybe I'm a little bit
older than you but we definitely
overlapped where we're from we're both
from Long Island so I think that's
that's pretty cool I'm actually from
Suffolk County though so you're you're
from Nassau County if I understand
that's right but anyway it's the longest
Island in America at least might be one
of the longest islands in the world
we're going to get to the world we're
going to talk about a phenomenal new
contribution to the world uh and that's
balaji's newest book so first of all
thank you so much for joining us uh it's
early where you are it's late where I am
we'll turn up the zoom you know tune up
our appearances maximally uh how are you
doing today
good I'm doing great thanks for joining
us so as I mentioned I always like to
start off an interview with a renowned
author such as yourself by doing that
which you are never supposed to do which
is to judge a book by its cover but
biology as you know uh what else do you
have to go on when you see a new book
and all you have is cover and the
author's name and the subtitle so I
thought you would start by uh how did
you come up with the name the network
State the subtitle the cover design and
uh the overall Gestalt of this uh
magnificent new book well thanks
um appreciate it uh yeah so
um you know maybe you can put the cover
just to my left or something while I'm
talking about it yeah
um you know the the network status a
seemingly abstract concept that uh one
of the important things that we did is
um illustrate it like as visually as
possible on the cover of the book and
then later in uh the network state in
one image very early in the book in
chapter one like basically the you know
uh we just never seen one sentence then
we get to never seen one image because
two or three pages it's the book for the
add okay and uh the reason for that is
that something that's really abstract or
difficult to grasp often uh you know
pictures worth a thousand words and when
you see essentially a social network
with some sort of
um moral value or uh you know some
belief that then holds territory around
the world that's not contiguous in one
place that kind of illustrates what the
network state is and so what that cover
illustrates are three different you know
um groups that you know represented by
like a yin yang symbol and the Vitruvian
symbol and the Bitcoin symbol that own
different pieces of territory around the
world but really their capital is in the
cloud
and so you know they are they have
projections down onto the Earth they
might have you know a million people in
the cloud and a few thousand people at
each node on the earth so it might even
be like a thousand to one ratio but
those nodes are actually quite important
and those people in the cloud of course
are scattered all over the Earth but
there's a few points of physical
concentration and the fact that those
exists are actually very important
um because it means that it's not a
purely digital thing it does have a
physicality to it it's Cloud first land
last but not land never and so the cover
of the book is sort of a way of showing
that poetically without
um you know all of the bells and
whistles that you'd use to show it a
little a little more
um you know granularity or operationally
and uh then if you go to the network
state in one image and you click on that
image there or if you look at the GIF uh
in that in that thing
that gives a more zoomed in view where
now you're actually seeing a census and
you're not just seeing that a social
network is crowdfunding territory if
you're seeing more than the four nodes
or three nodes that are shown on the
cover of the book you're seeing more
like 50 nodes and those 50 nodes around
the world have between like a thousand
to ten thousand people or actually some
go all the way down to one person just
somebody in their room or two you know
you might you might require a node to
have at least two people fine okay but
uh you know let's say it goes down to
two but up to you know twenty thousand
people and uh but then the whole thing
sums to a million people around the
world and it sums to a certain number of
square meters around the world and it
sums to a certain amount of annual
income around the world if you take all
on-chain income and then that second
image the numbers in one image just a
few pages in shows how you can build
something that looks a lot like a state
it's got a population income and real
estate footprint comparable to that
Legacy States but you're sewing together
pieces of territory and population from
around the world much as Bitcoin was a
decentralized currency this is a recipe
for a decentralized state right so
that's what those early images on the
cover and uh in in chapter one are meant
to convey
um and I wonder if we could uh
immediately kind of get into the nuts
and bolts of of what a network actually
is and the kind of as as I understand
the fundamental you know kind of
Newton's laws or shorting our equation
of network behaviors metcalf's law uh
which which I kind of think about in
many ways but one is entropically and
and how you percolate out you know
sources on nodes and how those nodes
feed together information and the
fundamental unit of information I wonder
if we could start by uh sort of you know
going back to to bitcoin itself it's
obviously Central I mean you play a huge
role in the story of Bitcoin uh but uh
but I wonder uh I've often wondered
there's nothing about Bitcoin that
couldn't have been implemented you know
20 years ago 30 years ago uh why do we
think it took so long I mean I'm not
diminishing natoshi or whatever
satoshi's uh well at all or any of your
contributions but fundamentally it's
it's a relatively simple algorithm that
that's what gives it so much power why
do you think it came about when it did I
guess that's a succinct way of asking
this question why did it take so long or
or maybe it wasn't so long from your
perspective yeah I mean
um
so the thing is that certain things you
know like for example the hash functions
that Satoshi used were not available you
know 30 years ago to my knowledge like
the elliptic curve work and so he had to
snap together stuff that was uh like if
what was the exact date that shot 256
was
published
um 2001 I think by NSA and then
um rip MD
I know predecessors are 128 and it
wasn't you know completely yeah no it's
true there were there were hash
functions so like basically
um I think there are a few things first
is remember you you needed to have
bandwidth suitable enough and enough
people who had computers that were
permanently connected to the internet to
host the Bitcoin blockchain and
um
you know probably even in the year 2001
maybe you could have done that in
Academia but at least the initial vision
of lots of Home computers doing that and
being always online and synchronizing
back and forth I mean peer-to-peer
networks you know he cites he uses the
term peer-to-peer in the white paper
which had at the time fallen out of
fashion but like Kaza and Skype and so
on they weren't like that old right like
Skype you know launched I think 2004 if
I'm not mistake 2003 okay so it's like
about five or six years after Skype and
then there's a financial crisis which
was the cultural trigger yeah so you had
to have P2P networking you had to have
shots 56 or probably something so at
least that came out 2001 it was
relatively soon after all those pieces
came together but you know
um could it potentially be done sooner
maybe the interesting thing is there
wasn't to my knowledge of leibniz to
satoshi's Newton
that say it's not like there was
somebody who is putting those pieces
together in quite that way at that time
and they just you know it's not like a
theory ethereum is wonderful it's
amazing but it's not like it shipped
you know three months later with a
different notation but the same Concepts
uh it you know it was it was something
where Satoshi genuinely
pioneered this new thing that people
really didn't get for a while uh because
he started with different premises in
the existing system and so if you start
with different premises then you know
whatever you build from that it's not
obvious that it's going to actually be
useful like for example if people are
like okay we're into the concept of
internal combustion engines and you
build a better one then it's very easily
accepted that it's ten percent better
you don't want you know right energy or
something when you're talking about a
decentralized digital currency it's not
even obvious still to many people that
they want that right why wouldn't I just
you know have the bank hold my money or
the government hold my money they don't
understand the concept of digital
property rights or what have you yet and
so it's still a non-obvious thing to
many people
um but I don't know I think about 50 of
people get it thereabouts uh depending
let's say 50
um there's hundreds of millions of
people around the world who hold
cryptocurrency and then a large enough
number of people now get it on some
level that they at least understand
why it's around let's put it like that
whether it's 50 it's hundreds of
millions of people that's a better term
for it and absolute number is a large
number of people who get it at this
point
so that's that's the answer to uh to you
know
um Why didn't it happen sooner
go ahead yeah go ahead go ahead
you'd also ask earlier like why the term
the network State
um and uh that is just something where
you know sometimes you name a book last
or you know this is something where in a
sense I wrote the book in a few months
and since I wrote the book in several
years because I've been thinking about
some of the concepts for a while for
example one critical concept is uh
people don't just judge a book by its
cover they will often judge a book by
its title yeah you know for example how
many people have read the end of History
versus they've heard the title and a
little quick summary and they argue with
it based on their sort of compressed
understanding right that's not
necessarily a completely wrong thing to
do because that compressed thing
um you know is something but what
happens is obviously in a in a in a
compressed summer you can't answer every
single critique and criticism and so on
and some people would you know say oh
fukuyama didn't consider this this and
that and history is so stupid and often
he had entertained those counter
arguments in the book which you you
cannot easily fit into a sentence or two
right right yeah with that said that
said uh a phrase travels right like uh
much much farther than a full book so
you have to kind of armor up that phrase
and have it do as much work for you as
possible just as an example like
um why why do people call themselves
Democratic socialists okay okay in their
very limited space to kind of convey a
message they use the very first word to
say no no we're Democratic socialists
we're not like the Communists who are
undemocratic socialists right so they
are intentionally using some very scarce
you know verbal real estate to preempt
right the most significant the most
significant bit is carrying doing a lot
of the work in that sense in that first
doing a lot of the work that's right
because at the time you know like
certainly the mid 20th century that you
know otherwise it would be the
undemocratic Socialists right that's why
other folks will call themselves you
know like the Christian socialists so
we're not Progressive that's right
progressives right and then you're
regressing yeah yeah exactly but but
like like if you say Christian socialist
some people would say that right or
Liberation theology you know in South
America well we're not Godless
Communists we're godful Communists uh
you know and so so so often that that
word is chosen in such a way as
to sort of embrace the fact that people
will often just engage with the phrase
hey friends just a quick request while
you're enjoying this video to leave a
thumbs up my thumb's a little bit
preoccupied with all Carl Sagan over
here but I hope yours is free enough to
leave a like it really helps me with the
algorithm and for extra credit homework
assignment leave a comment down below
what you're enjoying about this video
now back to the show
and um
Network State you can get a lot out of
just the phrase first is Network
replaces nation and so it sounds starts
with an N that's just like a small thing
but it's just like helps fit in the
brain in the same way right second is
the network actually if you read the
book there's like four definitions of
network state that are interesting the
first is network is actually the people
and you know the niche and the state are
different
um you know Nation it's like shared
birth shared you know shared descent
like the same uh root word in Latin is
like natality right so nasis I think and
um
whereas the state is the administrative
layer above that people so the nation
the statistics of the people the state
is the management it's like labor and
and management in a factory they're
actually quite distinct okay and so you
could have the Japanese nation and the
American state over it you could have
the the Kurdish nation and the Turkish
State over it or the catalonian nation
and the Spanish state over and those are
different okay and
um the or you could have the Japanese
nation in the Japanese State and the
Japanese say it's just a subset of those
Japanese people and a totally different
subset would result in a very different
kind of state right once you realize
there's a separable which is not obvious
because you usually hear them as a
compound term
um
then you're like okay how can we
separate and then recombine in a
different way a network state is one
where the network replaces the nation
and now it's not necessarily common
descent or common physical location for
hundreds or thousands of years but it's
a proposition Nation it's a it's
literally a nation of shared belief and
uh but that's a network today because
those folks are online so the first way
is you swap in the network for the
nation the second is the network because
it's on computers it's logic it's code
is the state itself so Network state is
a way of talking about a state that is
governed by the rules of the network
such as
um you know laws code right like the you
know the whole
uh Larry lessig concept right so the
state the governance is now digital
right yeah a third is when you talk
about a state usually people are
thinking about something that's got
physical terrain that it controls right
and in the network State
um it does have physical training that
it controls but that physical terrain is
a network
around the world uh it's a physical
Network it's little pockets just like on
the the books cover as we were just
talking about
um to the land of the network state is a
network okay and the fourth and perhaps
most abstract definition is in the book
I talk about like God stated Network as
these three leviathans that people are
essentially implicitly invoke on a daily
basis like they live their lives they
often don't think of this explicitly but
it's like you know who is the strongest
force in their life is it almighty God
right is it the US military yeah or is
it encryption you know what is it that
stops you from stealing in the 1800s
it's because you you thought you got you
know hit by a lightning bolt you'd get
smoked by God if you if you stole 1900s
you might not believe in God but the
boys in blue are there they're throwing
you in jail the state will punish you
right and the 2000s on the computer
network where there is no obvious God
and there is no state right it's the
network that will that will uh won't let
you steal either the social network will
swarm you or the encrypted Network or
the encryption will will stop you from
transferring the funds and what I mean
by that is if somebody steals your
cryptocurrency and you're in
Idaho and they're in you know
um Eastern Europe or something like that
to go to the Idaho Police Department and
file a case that's no longer a
geographical thing the the state is as
powerless there relatively speaking I
mean maybe you can try and get the FBI
or something to do something but the
state is not set up for that any more
than the church was set up to really be
an administrator in the same way that a
secular state is you know so the network
is like a New Leviathan and then Network
State refers to the fact that these
leviathans are like you know almost like
fundamental forces and you can take
fusions of them and network State fuses
the last two right so you can get a lot
of the title go ahead yeah no there's
there's certainly a million different
launching off points and I should say
we're limiting this conversation to just
twice as long as the conversation you
had with Lex Friedman uh so uh but you
know because we are heading into
election you know day in America here
and uh you're you're you're not located
here currently but you obviously have
opinions about I just want to turn to
that one phrase that you said that one
of the networks you know that was
enforcement mechanisms of the past in
fact mentioned by the founding fathers
in the Constitution was that this was a
constitution that was wholly unfit for a
non-god-fearing population in other
words God you know fearing their nature
was essential even the ones that were
deist or even atheists of the founding
fathers and so they implemented
something which would seem to be sort of
uh subjective and hard to implement in
the purely cryptographic or you know
chain-based reality when you could do
everything with
50.000.1 percent you know consensus and
that was the Electoral College and
obviously there's lots of moves to get
rid of that but that's you know wholly
uh you know effectively uh meant to undo
the tyranny of the majority and I I
guess I wonder you know is there is
there a room in a network state for
those um four different you know kind of
Concepts or previous Concepts to still
do useful work in other words uh if you
had a you know a say a theocracy you
know could it also tolerate a network
State and in other words are they
exclusive say the belief that held
together civilization for thousands of
years and instantiated laws between men
and fellow men
are is there room uh for in such a uh in
such a concept as a network State uh for
God or maybe the revert you know a
Converse question you know if you have a
state that is uh you know purely based
on uh you know some sort of notion of
Ten Commandments whatever you want is
your moral code is there room for you
know another power to make these
decisions almost exclusively numerically
it would seem
so is there room for another power to
make like political decisions is that
what you're saying yeah I mean is this
sort of replacement I mean if you if you
viewed it uh if you viewed the United
States Constitution as being you know
suitable as the founding father said for
only for a God-fearing population then
you know is yeah is the network State
you know excluding God or you know vice
versa
oh so it's not
um so in fact you know that's I have
this concept in the book called The the
one commandment which um you know I I do
think that whatever you do for a new
community I think it's I'm sympathetic
to Dallas I like Dallas but the big
problem with a lot of dows decentralized
autonomous organizations they're not
really autonomous and they're not really
even that decentralized except for the
location of the people they often start
with a token they start with money right
and the problem with that is
have you ever seen Idiocracy uh yeah
yeah actually my judges uh graduate
physics graduate of UC San Diego
great okay so I'm gonna have him on the
podcast he promised to come in all right
great well so
um
there's a there's a scene there where
he's like wow you like money too me too
right and you know the reason that's
actually a great scene is it just
emphasizes the fact that money is
universal barter it's universally
valuable and it's usually valuable then
clearly it's not specifically something
I mean everybody will be like okay yeah
I'll take 10 bucks you know no matter
all their ideological differences or
whatever they'll basically 10 take some
money and so what that means is a Dao
can bring people in and oh wow we've got
10 000 people in our Discord why are
there ten thousand people in a Discord
because they're just waiting for an
airdrop and they'll type it in a funny
way win air drop or something like that
right
and they're saying it kind of joking but
they're not they're the only reason that
they're there is for the money they
don't really have a shared belief
they're kind of right and so the problem
is that while you know economics and
money and so on that's good you have to
have a belief structure first uh of
common values otherwise there's many
different ways that people can like scam
or you know engage in low trust activity
with each other if they don't think of
themselves as part of basically the same
group and they're being something other
than just this transaction at hand right
they have to think of themselves as
being an iterated game with the other
person and uh you know just like
I mean there's a thousand examples of
this but like uh you know shrinkflation
that is right yeah you know you see yeah
yeah you're selling I don't know uh milk
but you sell it for the same price and
you call it you know uh you know milk
but you you just you make the container
it has like uh less volume of liquid in
it you know right and same size box or
or yeah but but you got less less fluid
mass less mass in there and and you're
just kind of you know you're sort of
that's like a company which is
um
it's reducing the amount that you are
getting for the same price but it's kind
of tricking people into still buying it
you know it's on the it's on the line
right and there's a lot of that
borderline stuff that happens if there
isn't sort of shared values between the
buyer and the seller and this is for a
thousand things it's for you know it's
for labor it's for you know management
it's for a thousand things right
so you kind of have to start whether
it's with a shared belief in God you
certainly need a shared belief of some
in something you know and you know
historically you could say the belief in
God well that's like a decentralized and
scalable enforcer why because someone
who's a God-fearing man you know that
that old phrase well you know even if
there wasn't a state around to punish
them even if there wasn't a state even
if they were at the head of the state if
they feared god well they'd behave even
when no one was watching them because oh
you know they might get hit by a
lightning bolt or something like that
right and so there's a there's a
rational sense in which you want an
irrational actor who's a quote
God-fearing person that behaves even
when they cannot be punished or more
generally they believe in something
bigger than you know just the state
itself they behave well even other than
that right and uh
so so yeah so in the book I do talk
about this one command concept which is
you know I'm not saying that every new
startup Society or aspiring Network
State needs to have its own 10
Commandments but you might be able to
have one commandment which is one moral
critique of society that where you think
your Society is better and you kind of
need that level of focus just like a
startup company needs a product that is
better than you know the existing
Marketplace on one very core Dimension
because it's very hard to improve on
even one dimension you have to kill it
on that dimension
here you need a moral Improvement on the
on the uh on Society at large and you
say for example just give two examples
cul-de-sac okay their cul-de-sac.com
they're saying cars are bad right and so
they're for a car free neighborhood is
good walkability is good they start with
those moral premises okay and from that
they derive the concept of let's build a
car free walkable neighborhood with the
cars to push the boundary
a totally different concept is a gift
kaft okay also star of society and they
start with
um
Mobility is good so van life is good
okay so cul-de-sac is walkability I
don't want to touch a car at all gift is
a different thing which is I want to be
able to see this you know huge outdoors
and travel and not be bound to one
location therefore I'm going to live in
a car
I'm a city free life not a car free life
okay I'm gonna see The Great Outdoors
and so on what's funny is the same
person might actually think oh both of
these are pretty cool but they're both
mutually incompatible right rejections
of you know modern society yet the COS
are friendly okay and that's actually a
pretty interesting thing where of course
you couldn't combine car free and living
in a van at the same time okay uh
obviously still you could imagine
someone picking like okay I like to walk
with Liberty I also like the concept of
actually seeing this giant country that
we're in and not just you know seeing it
in in picture books actually going and
bathing in a stream and you know today
I'm in Nevada and tomorrow I'm in
Montana that's actually pretty cool I
can just drive up there wow awesome
right
um
and uh you know more generally you could
have for example a carnivore Community
where they only eat meat or a vegan
Community where they only eat vegetables
and fruit or whatever and both of those
would probably be healthier than the
McDonald's community that is the default
right so essentially what I say in the
book is that you do need a common belief
and I think that's abstracted by the way
that's not just like you know okay
biology just saying something that is a
distillation of
countless different communities that
have been found in the past and uh you
know one thing I quote is the um
I think uh Sir Walter rally and you know
some of the early
um
American communities uh there's this
historian Paul Johnson an interview with
Charlie Rose which I quote in the book
and uh
you know what what that historian
observes is that the early American
colonies that were for-profit often just
gave up in the winter but those that had
a religious belief continued through the
tough Winters just like those who are
zealous about crypto continue through
the tough crypto Winters right it's
somewhat analogous it's kind of you know
it's obviously something of a joke it's
not completely a joke right you need
something more than money to carry you
forward where the money isn't there you
need to be irrational to achieve the the
greatest results right so I wonder in
those uh in those communities that you
talked about if they would allow any any
taxi cab numbers and I wonder if you can
expound a little bit on your fascination
with uh one such taxi cab number 1729.
uh and the context I want to uh so I'd
love to hear it in your own voice
because you're such a a champion of
ramanujan and uh Titanic contributions
but I wonder you know in reading the
book and coming to the end it's you know
essentially a love letter at the very
end to him uh but um but the centrality
of math and you know math is sort of the
in some sense the the most abstract I
mean I I always say you can't hand me a
triangle I mean but the human mind can
think about a triangle you can't Hand Me
Infinity we can think about Infinity but
the level where you know we sort of meet
uh the instantiation of the network
State I think for the first time it
really would be at a base layer
predicated on math right I mean a lot of
the
um operational Behavior and the you know
consensus and so forth and obviously the
monetary exchange would all be math
based
um and so it reminds me of of this
famous essay by Eugene vigner a famous
physicist mathematician physicist who
spoke of the unreasonable effectiveness
of mathematics in the physical sciences
wondering why for example you know the
square root of negative one why that has
any interplay with uh with
electromagnetic fields right yeah sure
yes and statistics which from which
comes from the properties of the state
the mathematics of the state that's the
etymology of Statistics as you know
um that you know the classic P variable
key feature metric of that is the normal
distribution which describes populations
as a normal population it has a number
Pi in it why does the ratio of the
circle's circumference to its diameter
play any role in the governance of a
Nation so I wonder if you could talk a
little bit about the centrality of mass
in the network States and the various
configurations thereof and uh and and
maybe May me also along the way we'll
get into ramanujan and why he's so
important to you
sure yeah so on Centralia math you know
one thing you just mentioned earlier in
the conversation is that you know the
core thing about the network is
metcalf's Law and certainly metcalf's
law you know Network effect scales in
square that's that's theoretically
important
two things though first is depending on
the actual network uh it's often you
know much less than N squared for
example that's number of potential
connections but you know of the four
billion people on Facebook
um it's not like they're actually all
literally connected directly to each
other
um there's you know some people have
said it's like more like n log n or yeah
the small world approximation right yeah
exactly it's more like K times n or
something like that in terms of the
actual and you could actually Facebook
itself could graph this and there's a
bunch of research on this I haven't
looked at the exact curve but it's not
exactly N squared that's kind of one
yeah the second thing is maybe deeper
Point relates to the mathematics of it I
think for the network the most important
concept thing I think about the most is
a very simple seeming thing but that you
can get very far with it and that is the
concept of the geodesic graph geodesic
distance versus the geographic distance
and uh the geographic distance or the
great circle distance is the distance
between two points on the surface of the
Earth like as the crow flies from one to
the other okay and um
you know you can you can think of that
as you know plane flight distance you
can make a somewhat more complicated
version where you know for example South
Africa and Argentina you could easily
fly from one to the other but to walk
from one to the other would have been
difficult so you had to go all the way
around the Bering Strait and down you
know the US right like I'm sure someone
has done that ancestral like migration
of humanity the humanity didn't come
from South Africa but you know what I
mean like that huge walk across Asia or
whatever right maybe it's possible in
the in the thaw of the you know it's
probably not possibly where you can't
land bridge right yeah yeah land bridge
so
um point is you know whether you're
talking about it as a crow flies or how
primitive man might walk right
um or or surf or whatever uh that's
that's like the physical distance in the
world and that's the distance that we're
used to in terms of saying people are
close or far or what have you but the
geodesic distance The graft geodesic is
the number of uh Degrees of Separation
in a social network
and that's actually also a distance
metric and uh in in the technical sense
like you know D of uh a comma B and it's
like non-negative and you know it's it's
got it satisfies a triangle and quality
and whatever
um
and uh the the graph geodesic okay
um that is something which is
you can you can build a geography on it
you can build a topology on it you uh
you basically have
um something where uh you know that that
shortest path distance between two nodes
okay
um
it's like
it's something that you can well first
of all you can do a projection of a
graph down into two dimensions and so
you can make graph proximity in this
relatively High dimensional space you
can visualize it in two or three
dimensions but second is it gives you a
different intuition about how the space
works for example the node can instantly
connect to another node just by
friending a bunch of people
or it can instantly be very far away by
blocking them yeah right that we know
for like an individual that now extends
to entire groups which we haven't really
seen as much on the internet but a group
can suddenly become adjacent to another
group by building a ton of connections
there
or it can suddenly break away from a
group by you know cutting it it's as if
every continent and nation in the world
was on Wheels right you know one thing
we sort of take for granted is Russia
the entity has kind of been the same
place and it has ancient geographical
relationships you know with turkey and
with Eastern Europe and the Caucasus and
then also on its Asian boundary with you
know I should say ancient but they have
long-standing relationships with Japan
and China right yeah and so you know the
borders May expand and contract
and that means you know ekraine is
inside during the Soviet era and it's
outside but
essentially Russia has been in the same
place that we kind of take that for
granted by contrast in the cloud with
the geodesic distance
um you can have you know ethereum as
this cluster and then Solana suddenly
just appears next to it
right and it's competing with it or what
have you right and then uh you know
Monero is there and then Z cash just
appears next to it okay and this is when
you take a tech company uh and it's got
some market and then another tech
company just appears next one is
competing for that same Market or then
it just bows out of the market and just
disappears okay these are like large
groups of people can just like
materialize in Space the intuition is
more like virtual reality where Kaboom a
bunch of people can just appear and they
just disappear now that's digital so the
speed is instant
but it's a geography that's closer to
our hunter-gatherer ancestry where
you're wandering around and suddenly
boom Another tribe could just appear
and you might be in competition right or
boom it could leave right
this is just a totally different way of
thinking about how states are organized
and what have you because the
fundamental assumptions about proximity
and how governance is done if the
geography keeps changing then you cannot
assume that the geographical borders
will remain constant yeah if people can
connect across borders you cannot assume
that governance within borders is
necessarily the right thing you know as
I was saying to like Lex like you know
you know what's order older than borders
is no borders right because you had
hunter-gatherers roaming the entire
world and there's that aspect of
humanity that desires to travel the
world and see everything and not be
bound and there's the other aspect that
wants you know there's no place like
home right that's a fundamental tension
within humanity and
um the math I think illustrates that
where you start realizing the geography
of the cloud is just very different than
the geography of the land you can
teleport you can be adjacent you can be
infinitely far with blocking you can
move groups nearby you can move groups
far away
it's it's as if you know these clouds
like would float around and there's much
more Dynamic and mobile and evanescent
and so on than the geography blade so I
think the metaphor actually you know
cloud and land you can go pretty far
with that go ahead so
um I'm thinking back uh just to close
the loop on ramanujan so um oh yes I
wanted to ask you you know first of all
there are two countries that are formed
in 1947-48 uh Israel and India slash
Pakistan
um what do you contribute the success of
these two different populations they
figure prominently in the book uh you
know in one way or another and some of
the work and conversations that you had
um what makes them so you know uh either
you know prototypical of good or bad
aspects of potential Network State
material and what do you attribute to
success or the
um you know they they far outnumber most
you know kind of ethnicities or
nationalities at least if you take it of
the Jews as a as as you know as a
ethnicity only but you know Indians and
Jews do pretty well when it comes to
Nobel prizes okay uh you know but uh
nobody's perfect right so um but tell me
what do you attribute uh you know this
too and and what is ramanujan
specifically I mean he he figures
prominently in your thinking obviously
and I don't think you've talked as much
about him specifically so what does he
mean to you yeah yeah yeah so so uh you
know ramonagen
um
is has probably most people watching
this know India's uh you know most
famous mathematician and
um you know had a very romantic life in
the sense uh you know tragic but you
know like movie worthy and there's uh
you know you know a book and a movie
called The Man Who do infinity and
actually Goodwill Hunting is based I
believe in part on on his life and
essentially was this mathematical genius
that grew up in you know poverty in
India and um
then what happened was uh he you know
was able to figure out a big chunk of
math on his own and wrote these letters
to all these mathematicians most of whom
ignored him the one guy GH Hardy in the
UK paid attention and basically
airlifted uh Urban Jan out and thus
began just a rampage Through Math and
you know romanian's notebooks today
still
um you know there's there's journals
devoted just to them but who just write
down these formulas and then you know
just with intuition he'd get these you
know equations right sometimes he had a
proof often he didn't but quite often
those those amazing identities somebody
could prove them with a lot of effort
but he would just like you know spit it
out like a neural network and may not be
able to explain the process necessarily
but you could check them and they're
very plausible and um
unfortunately he died very young and uh
you know when he on his deathbed
um you know the uh Hardy was coming in
to try to you know cheer him up and said
oh you know there's this taxi cab that
we came in on the license plate was very
boring its number was 1729 and he said
no it's uh some of two cubes in uh it's
the first number with some of two cubes
in two different ways one two people's
12 cubed equals 90 equals 10 cubed right
and that's kind of like what equals mc
squared is for you know the west and
India right like because it's uh it's
just like this cool equation I mean
it's it's on the one hand kind of
trivial you know once you know it okay
you're just cubing numbers and summing
them together it's more that he was just
on a first name basis with every number
and could just like whip out this random
identity you know when someone asked him
right about something right right and um
so so that's actually something which is
sort of symbolizes to me all of what I
think of as the dark Talent of the world
you know just like the Hubble telescope
it's all about the dark matter right
because all of this dark Talent which
um potentially is just languishing in
obscurity and just like we had the
Hubble telescope we now have the mobile
telescope and we can go and find all
these people and we can pull them out
and we can
um
we can actually you know basically give
them the opportunities that both they
deserve and that the world needs because
we need more religions right we need all
this talent in you know uh all these
places that have just been kind of left
out of the 20th century the quote third
world or what have you or even the
second world you know people under
Communist States people in in poor
countries uh and now they're actually
not so poor yeah so so this is something
which you know has kind of a
mathematical meaning cultural meaning
it's you know it's obviously important
for India but it's important for the
rest of the world
um and it's something that I think about
a lot I've thought about for many years
and I think now the time is right to
potentially go and
um in the remote first world you know
try and find these extra monuments yeah
and I want to dovetail that
um first by asking a question I asked
Michael Saylor uh almost two years ago
now and that was what is the purpose of
money what is the value of money I you
know I said to him he's a he's a
bachelor he has no kids no you know no
X's no spouses of any kind uh you know
he said he's you know his money is
basically going to be for him and then
he's going to save it up and then he's
going to apply it to sailor Academy and
um education and so forth but I also
what's the purpose of money you know
that's what you're going to do with it
uh but what's the purpose of it and he
basically said no power and and money is
you know is basically stored up you know
energy that can be you know displaced
and used in a variety of ways and I said
Michael I hope you're not you know
forming some like militia you know the
Sailor Army he has a sailor Army you
know obviously but but not of the
violent kind and may it always be like
that but what is a team allergy what
what does money do for you I said to him
you know like from uh what Charlie
Sheen's character said the garden Gecko
and Wall Street you know the first
version of it said you know how many
Yachts can you water ski behind uh what
does money mean to you uh in contrast to
Michael or any other uh guest that I may
have had on
um I think a money is a tool
uh not an end in its own right
um I've you know nothing against money
but um it's very much like a
it's a it's a it's an acquired uh skill
that I've had in terms of you know I've
very much charted out as like a career
academic and it's just you know doing
doing math for a long time and stats and
you know genomics and what have you
um I didn't really think I didn't really
care about money too much
um and I still don't really care about
money I made myself realize okay it's an
important constraint that you need to
use to get things but there's some
people who wake up in the morning and
they go to sleep at night and all
they're thinking about is how to
increase their balance and what would
have you right right and
um instead you know really uh for
example let's say that you wanted to
understand
The genome okay if you get a grant of 50
million dollars and each genome costs
you a thousand dollars to sequence
that's a historic thousand dollar genome
prices yeah like you know 10 10 years
ago well you're limited to 50 000
genomes but if you can figure out a
business model that makes you even a
hundred dollars per genome
on net you're now Unlimited
in the number of genomes you can
sequence because each new one it adds to
the uh to your data set and um you can
just keep going right so if it turns out
that you need to find a way to sequence
a million genomes in order to understand
human biology that
Now by by solving the money problem you
know by solving the economics and
figuring out a business model that can
generate that data you can now
accumulate enough data to be able to
diagnose and potentially eventually
treat diseases right that's the way that
I kind of think about things
um that's what originally got me into
you know one of the reasons you know
that got me into actually okay let's
build a business rather than just doing
things in Academia
because business can scale obviously in
an academic research paper is not meant
to scale that's a limited study limited
study size this is meant to potentially
grow to infinity and for those things
that need large data sets to understand
the world you're going to need that and
then you get into other aspects where
um if you want true Independence
academic Independence well
um if you believe that you have the
skills to get you know tenure in in a in
the hard Sciences at a university you
are overlapping with it's not identical
to but it is overlapping with the skills
required to become independently Wealthy
by you know your mid-30s or something
like that and if you if you can do that
well then you've got tenure in a
different way right tenure itself is
like a illiquid asset where you can sort
of trade it between universities and you
can be tenured at X place and you can
trade it for a 10-year track at y place
or Z Place relatively illiquid but it's
somewhat tradable whereas
um money if if you just had the runway
for uh you know 50 years of you know
just being able to live without
you know going and doing anything you
could just devote that to academics or
open source software or what have you
that is in a sense a kind of tenure it
is uh it's an unbundled version where it
doesn't come with the quote you know
Prestige of you know a legacy University
or what have you but it's more advanced
just in other ways because that money is
a negotiable asset you can just chip a
little thing off of it and then you can
go and decide to go and do your open
source work in the Bahamas right that's
pretty nice yeah you know like on
balance and doesn't initially have to be
Lambos or whatever but you can just go
and code on the beach or be in a warm
area or something like that right that
that's nice on the margins right you
know uh you can hire a research
assistant you don't have to go and spend
twenty thousand dollars or you don't
have to like go and write a grant get
twenty thousand dollars or fifty
thousand dollars for a hundred thousand
dollars even for a research assistant
you just do it out of your own pocket
right
um so that's what money means to me is
it's a tool to
figure out uh to acquire knowledge
eventually
um even if there's a lot of indirections
in between a and b
so why do you think that you know I made
this statement I had the opportunity to
spend some time with Peter Thiel a
couple weeks ago and um I said to him
you know a fact that I you know come
across in my research and and that was
that you know there's basically no one
who won the Nobel Prize in physics at
least
um or even in economics uh died with a
net worth substantially greater than you
know his unfortunately most most not
unfortunately but just the fact that
most of the Nobel Prize winners are male
uh only two living female Nobel Prize
winners in physics but but anyway none
of them died Einstein included Charlie
Townes invented the laser
um and uh you know that the Shockley
invented the transistor uh you know they
are responsible for you and I having
this conversation you know a billion
fold over right and they died basically
with less you know net worth than their
Nobel prizes now obviously when I asked
them and I asked out your alma mater
Guido in Benz at Stanford who won the
Nobel prize in economics last year I
understand you know why you know why
aren't there why aren't all these Nobel
laureates and economics billionaire
multi-billionaires
not connoting that you know the
conflating rather than the fact that you
know money is is the most important
thing but you know for someone who's
professional I mean you made a comment a
few minutes ago that that you know you
could the skills are sort of fungible
and that we could become you know a
businessman or woman or whatever become
independently but so few of us do it now
why is that um is sort of the question
to you why why do they know about why
don't they I mean obviously Einstein
wanted to to have more wealth and and
goes back a long way the tradition of
you know wanting to not have a patron to
have the fu money to do stuff on your
own without having to take you know 65
diversity classes and then anti-sexual
harassment classes and so forth that we
have to do and getting very little time
to spend with our students in the
laboratory so why do so few of us do it
and why do so many physicists and Nobel
Prize economics uh you know winners why
do they die poor you know relatively
speaking
well so first of all I mean it's just
it's maybe an obvious point but I'll
poke at this a little bit uh you know
depending on how you think about it the
point is not to die with a bunch of
unspent money yeah right now Bill uh
Perkins who wrote a book die with zero
on uh yeah that's a great book right
right is it basically like you know you
can't take it with you right what you
can do is you know do a few things you
can invest in longevity you can invest
in this concept I talk about in The Lex
Freedom podcast or tweet about called
genomic reincarnation briefly if you
believe that you know eukaryotic
chromosome synthesis is going to be as
feasible as microbial chromosomes it's
just kind of or you know already is
prokaryotic conversation since this
already is you might be able to sequence
yourself and then reincarnate yourself
in the future if somebody used that
money to pay for that reincarnation and
that synthesis in the future okay uh you
can say you pay for Life Extension you
could pay for that you could pay for
chronix like hellfini did
um you could certainly leave money to
some somebody or something and I I don't
have a good answer on that last part by
the way in terms of what to leave the
money to because I think a lot of the
foundations tend to get captured
um I think giving it to the government
is a waste
um you know but I also think giving it
to uh you know people's children I see
all these you know generally not always
of course there's always exceptions
generally speaking I find that many of
these nepotists who've like inherited
large amounts of money
feel guilty about it they have
civilizational diabetes because if you
haven't built you feel guilt right and
actually yeah the Getty family one of
the Scions or great grand you know
children is now supportive of the you
know uh let us uh deface artworks and
protest towards you know monets and Van
Gogh's and this is to protest fossil
fuel use which is the only reason that
anyone knows this person's name
on The Lex Friedman podcast that
actually resonates with a Year's proverb
where the you know the out the you know
the uh the the the the the
grandfather plants the tree uh the the
sun raises the tree and then the
grandson chops down the trees yeah shirt
sleeves to shirt sleeves in three
generations three generations exactly
yeah that's right and the thing about
this is basically
um
with something like that uh
what's happening there frequently and
there's this documentary called born
rich by I think the Johnson Johnson Air
which is worth looking at yeah
um what's happening there is I think a
few things first is sometimes people
feel I think wrongly but they feel guilt
not just that they didn't work hard but
oh my fortune was acquired in some ways
you know illegitimately oh my God right
but then they don't actually want to
give up their Fortune instead they want
to exped their sins by making you pay
for it right I made a billion dollars
because I have a billion dollars because
my great great whatever you know made a
lot of money in oil but I think oil is
bad today because I've read some stupid
propaganda so therefore uh you know what
I mean by that is like
um yes I think nuclear is better but
like you know
it's there's trade-offs is everything
and like uh you know you can
you won't have a modern civilization
without oil you wouldn't have something
to complain about for that right you
can't make a solar panel without some
oil processed along yeah exactly that's
right you know like the turbines you
know for wind or solar like first of all
they take a huge amount of space as if
you're seeing like a wind farm or solar
installation it's not like a look yeah
the density is just very low and second
is it's you know whatever but the point
is
um these folks for I think bad reasons
feel extremely guilty about oil
um
and the way they exped their sins is by
making you pay
all right
you know I don't think there's anything
wrong with inheriting wealth I think you
know when you hear people oh I'd be rich
as you if I inherited money you know to
some lottery winner look how many
lottery winners not only lose all their
money but like commit suicide or murder
like it's actually very difficult for
for these Scions or whatever to actually
Steward their money and and then
actually do something good with it but
as you're saying there is the guilt is a
is a very powerful emotion right so
right so the thing about inheritive I
mean I'm not like as I said I I don't
have a good answer on this as of now
yeah okay I don't think it works to give
it to a foundation often because that
foundation will allocate in a bad way
frequently Ford Foundation Rockefeller
Carnegie if not in my view being really
good and having to allocate money they
become very
um they just get inter you know
entrained with the establishment right
they are now
um they're just just allocates the same
stuff it's something unique I mean
actually the one thing that I do think
is a pretty good kind of Grant is like
the clay math Millennium prizes that I
actually think is pretty cool right
um that's hard to corrupt it's genuinely
benefiting all of humanity the solutions
to those math problems if they're
derived easily worth a million dollars
each
um and
that's that's it's hard to corrupt and
valuable through Infinity
um you know that it's possible that
maybe some open source thing or some
smart contract that executed what your
wishes could be as good possible
but um but yeah so so with respect to to
this uh I think that um
why do we get on the topic of inherited
wealth it was uh the change or you know
oh yeah so the Gettys right so
what happens is they exped their scenes
by making you pay there's something else
which happens which is when money is in
abundance then people want status and
when status is abundance people want
money right so when these folks are born
rich oh they have all the money okay
well now they want to be respected well
no one's going to respect them for just
being an oil Heir right by taking the
stand against oil now suddenly you know
oh wow the chattering classes say nice
things about them so they get positive
feedback right so the social incentives
drive it conversely if status is in uh
you know
um abundance you want money and this is
like what I think David Brooks wrote
about years ago I think it's like uh
Meghan McConnell has written about this
status income dysmogamy where you have a
journalist who is paling around with all
these wealthy people and you know
they're in fact concerned about what
they'll write but then they go home to
like a small apartment or something like
that and so status is much higher than
their income so what they do they
constantly write about how you know we
need to abolish billionaire errors and
so on the thing is they're actually
upper middle class typically or at least
middle class so in the top whatever
percent of the world it's only top 10
maybe 25 of the of the world and what
they say they want equality they don't
actually mean that they should be pulled
down to Global median income what they
mean is that tiny percent of four
percent of people above them should be
pulled down to them
right so by equality they actually want
ascendance right they actually want to
level up once you realize that that's
actually the goal you can pitch
something very different which is the
level up and that is actually the
difference where you know with the
founder mentality is is pitching
essentially the personal level up which
allows them to transcend which is
actually the true goal very few people
quote actually want equality even if
they purport to it what they want is for
those above them to be pulled down not
for themselves to be reduced to the
global media technology I mean you've
moved to yeah out of America so do you
feel like
um will there ever be a scenario where
you could see
America being a good place for you to
put your your resources your talent your
time and your money
um I mean obviously like this is a very
complicated topic that's hard to produce
to just a sound bite but I think the
short version is I am have always been
and I'm still in favor of American
values
um I think the particular American state
and establishment has produced those
values broadly and in particular you
know the uh I mean the US was the UN
Undisputed hyperpower of 1991. with even
moderately good management you could
have had probably a hundred years of
peace and prosperity you know something
like that right and what's happened is
the U.S establishment over the last 30
years has probably blown the biggest
lead in human history
you know San Francisco is being turned
into like this you know open-air drug
Den failed City failed City I mean to
the north here I can make that yeah
exactly it's happening here too I mean
then that's right used to be the last
Bastion now there's uh homeless camps
that stretch for a five square city
blocks and I've had the mayor on my
podcast he's a Democrat Todd Gloria I've
had Republicans on and uh seems like
there's just unwilling to really take on
these these huge challenges which as
you're saying we have the resources I
mean California is the fourth largest
economy in the world now
yeah it's in fact actually in some ways
it's the money is the bad part because
many poor countries around the world
manage basic functional civil order they
have far less money the money is not the
constraint at all it's actually the
wrong belief system and it took me a
while to understand what the heck was
going on because you know with Communism
at least I kind of understood it at the
level of okay let's all gang up and Rob
this rich guy and have some ideological
justification for that right Genghis
Khan but with an ideological overlay you
know that's like stolen right
um so communism at least I didn't agree
with it but I understood it okay with
you know the wokeness that has taken
over these cities I'm like what
political ideology would actually want
to cover a city in feces like that just
seems negative some for everybody that
that's not even like you know yeah
yeah communism at least Market it as
zero-sum okay we will all rise while we
rob this rich guy you know who I see
rich I I get that even though I think
it's bad because I think it's actually
negative sum what actually happens is
the poor and the rich guy both end up in
the gulag you know everybody loses yeah
um but with with what this is like why
do people want to like cover the streets
and poop that seems obviously bad then I
realized that I actually a lot of these
activists you know and that's actually
where it's a big part of what's driven
by
and they have this mental model that oh
some Captain of industry walks out of
his high rise and he steps in poop and
now he understands the plight of those
who he's normally pushed out of sight if
you notice when we talk about the
homeless cell you know the um these
folks will say well I'm so sorry it's
visible to you huh you know as if it had
just existed and uh now it's suddenly
being made visible to you as opposed to
what's actually happened which is that
uh the provision of syringes and quote
safe injection sites and so on has
actually created a gigantic class of
folks who are either drug abusers and or
mentally ill and or uh you know have
some issue where you know that you know
you can you can decompose the quote
Homeless Problem the word doesn't
actually Encompass it there's folks who
are addicted to drugs there's folks who
are mentally ill there's folks who are
criminals there's folks who just want to
like you know live on the streets and
just have you know a handout or have you
and then there's folks who are genuinely
for a reason down on their luck and
living in a car or a van
um but that last group is not the same
as someone who will just you know
poop on the street and smash somebody
with a different populations yeah it's
different populations right and actually
the term quote homeless conflates fair
you know fairly different things so so
first of all you're mislabeling it the
word is wrong because you think oh that
means we need to build more houses
housing is not a cure for mental illness
okay girders are you know
just just totally different things
you're conflating two different things
and
um
the uh so so they just have the wrong
Concepts on this and you know once you
realize that this activist is looking
forward to this you know captive
industry being humiliated and seeing the
play the poor finally you realize that
actually what these folks are doing is
they're kind of using the homeless as
native advertising in the following
sense these you know somebody's mentally
ill is uh you know for example they
attacked a woman in San Francisco uh on
camera right outside her apartment like
this crazy guy was not like letting her
go inside this immigrant woman was
trying to get into her apartment do you
remember this thing it was like a few
years ago right yeah yeah and
and then uh what what is actually
happening is so that that woman might
you know survive fortunately she
survived this attack she was you know I
think relatively unharmed
but it was very scary you know she could
have just been like dragged into the
dark and who the heck knows right
and so what might happen I don't know
her specifically but what would happen
is okay come around the next election
she would vote for somebody who promises
to solve the homeless problem or address
the homeless problem right and what does
that mean that means more budget to
quote solve the homeless problem and
that actually means more budget for
syringes and these Billboards in San
Francisco that say something like
um you know snort crack but don't don't
inject it right heroin right yeah yeah
I'm not even hold on I want to get the
exact billboard uh San Francisco drug
Billboards right
um
foreign
okay sure fine so so no overdose right
um change it up uh injecting drugs
carries the highest risk of overdose so
try smoking or snorting instead okay and
crop rotation crop rotation
yeah they put these on buses and of
course that you know like this is
marketed as being actually you know
being real come on man obviously you
know it's naive to say people won't use
drugs so therefore we just need to kind
of meet reality where it is and so on
this is like the total opposite of
people being like you know oh okay uh
everyone's going to be racist so
therefore we just kind of need to meet
reality where it is on this right so on
some it's like saying like a wife you
know her husband's going out of town and
she says oh you know in case you cheat
on me please use a condom I mean well
right it's it's basically it's something
which is like you know they are um
the what's actually happening and this
is a key step in this whole cycle that I
had to realize
That Homeless industrial complex
when it gets budget it increases the
size of the homeless problems
right well that's right in fact it's
opposite what happens is the number of
put activists and this homeless
industrial complex has grown with the
homeless population itself so it's to
feed the pigeon Society look at all
these pigeons oh my God and they're
actually creating the problem
they are exacerbating the problem and
they are paid to exacerbate the problem
and they're paid to not understand that
they're exasperating the problem they
whether you call it
um natural selection I I doubt it's like
fully conscious but their actions are
making the problem worse if they care
about right I mean mental illness is not
going to be cured by you know safe
syringes and uh and drug problems
certainly won't be either but it's like
that's the Band-Aid that you know covers
up the uh you know the the Triangular
knife blade Scar and and it's yeah
well I have to I have to I mean we're
such analogous things happen in a truly
you know networked State and then you
know again getting back to the question
like what would it take to return your
business back to California I mean to be
crude about it
uh
I don't know I mean like
what's it what does it take to return
your business back to Detroit what does
it take to return your business back to
like that what how about bringing it
back to Greece or Rome you know like
I think that era in Civilization is over
and I'm not I'm not like I shouldn't
suppose that you're not happy where you
are I I yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah sorry
no no I understand I understand what
you're saying I mean I can give a recipe
I'll come I'll come to that in a second
one thing I want to say also is
basically if you you know one thing
that's recently finally been kind of
featured in The Press is like the
mothers of these drug addicts right
um uh you know like mother of addict
slams you know San Francisco open air
drug policies basically these mothers
are seeing that they're kids who were
borderline their addiction is being
enabled by this homeless industrial
complex right so that is actually the
angle where you can see this is not
compassionate and it's actually
zombifying a previously functional human
being in the name of quote compassion
but it's actually you know turning
somebody into a dependent when they
could have potentially stood on their
own feet and being independent with a
different you know form of intervention
this is very similar to how this these
ngos this non-profit industrial complex
you know they want to be these uh
saviors in Africa and India and so on
and so forth and really investment is
independence and Charities dependence
like easterly and Levine have written
about you know stopping the aid and so
on because the aid is basically
something which is meant to give the
person who's quote giving it out a good
feeling right but it's all the whole you
know teacher man fish versus Jesus Jesus
said this 2000 years ago right yeah yeah
well right okay so actually you know and
but if you also look you know there's
this uh article by prisonomics which is
about the um the most effective
development program in human history
have you heard this one no is it the US
Army or something no it's actually
Nigeria's most effective development
plan in human history was just a
business plan competition oh really
guess what wealth creation basically the
thing is you know you can do I've talked
about this before but if you've got a
rich guy okay they can do one or two
things they can say I'm giving out
grants or I'm making Investments right
if you're giving out grants for a
non-profit or for individuals what will
you get you're going to get a queue of
people who are each competing to be the
most pathetic or sympathetic right in
extremists you know this is like slim
Dog Millionaire where they chop off the
limbs of this poor beggar to make them
more sympathetic okay there's actually
that learned helplessness they actually
self a harm in a sense either cycle
right they make themselves out to be
they real they think of themselves as
being as harmed as possible right and
you actually see this in um you know
there's the The Tech instabrag versus
the woke instasag what is the instasag
it's basically I'm you know autistic
disabled Maxwell intersectionality right
yeah maximum intersectionality I'm the
maximum victim I have established that I
am at the absolute bottom therefore you
need to put me at the absolute top right
the powerful victim right so
basically because they're at the
absolute bottom they win the status
competition right they are now at the
top of the queue for the grant because
they're the most pathetic and they're
the most deserving how could you
possibly give somebody else some money
and this is a learned helplessness to
win the game that's being set up and
what happens is of a hundred people who
are in the queue for that Grant uh maybe
one person quote wins by being the most
pathetic they really go all in they're
the method actor you know so to speak
right and the other 99 make themselves
weaker in the process they think you
know they think of the woe is me they
rent their garments right Etc right but
con by contrast when folks are competing
for an investment
rather than the woke instasag you have
the tech instabrag the insta brag is
like you know I uh graduated MIT in
physics in three years and I you know
had my first job at this and we got to
one mill rev and we sold it to this
right and often what you'll find is this
the same person
okay who's like a you know talented
college graduate will unconsciously talk
about all of their victimhood on in one
context and then talk about what a
killer they are in a different context
and they'll make that you know what I'm
saying right yeah no I've had that you
know for the scenario where it's like
you know uh you know I've I've come to
you know here and now my AmEx points are
you know they're not transferable to the
Delta lounge and I'm like wait a second
I thought you were like you know this
long suffering uh you know yeah right
well but actually but though even more
than that it's not like yes that's the
fact that their upper middle classroom
but the
um
the thing is that in order to get an
investment right like in Tech there's
this sort of insta brag you know five
second intro that people will use at
parties or whatever it's not actually
it's just like um it's just oh he he you
know
I know he he's a core contributor to
jQuery or or it's like they post and
their Rolex is showing or yeah they're
like well we'll see under Stanford grad
you know I mean so you're so I think
there's a very important difference here
you're bringing it back to their
frequent flyer lounge or the Rolex and
it's not really about the display of
wealth that's actually not what it is it
is the display of competence first 10
employees at stripe uh it is the you
know
um this this I I I was a core
contributor to jQuery it is a technical
or I see yeah YC class yeah exactly
that's right insofar as money is quoted
is we got the company to a 10 million
valuation and is acquired by Facebook or
whatever you know like 100 million
dollars is required right and
so it's not that oh I have a Rolex
nobody respects that that that's like
you know that's it huh go ahead it's
body yeah it's it's it's gaudy yeah yeah
I mean like I always say it shouldn't
say nobody I'm sure on Tinder I'm told
that you know they have to have some way
of differentiating the three guys that
are going to get the competing maybe you
know one girl right that may be the case
right but it's also like you know who
are you gonna attract with that or
whatever yeah fine you know but let's
say let's say that there's there's maybe
something to that point is
um that so what I'm what I'm talking
about though here is uh the the
ins instant kind of demonstration of
victim mode status versus the instant
demonstration of Victor status like I'm
I'm like I am the most convincing victim
and I'm the most convincing Victor those
are the two different things right where
you've got 100 people there competing
for this VC investment or Angel
investment and each person is just
straining you know be like close one
more deal right ship one more feature
you know improve the design just a bit
to kind of pip the other one and get
that investment right now what happens
in that that context yeah just like it's
like a it's like a hundred people
running a 400 meter dash okay it's true
only one wins but the other 99 they're
cardiovascular fitness is improved in
the process right these folks competing
for that investment that one investment
of a hundred thousand dollars makes 99
people stronger right they become better
at building better at designing even if
they don't win this time they become
overall as well creating for the
community right right and that's why
this you know if you actually the the
true charity is investment because
you're investing in their independence I
mean another way to see this by the way
is like
um if you're walking down the street and
uh let's say someone makes a hundred
thousand a year okay and they see
somebody you know like uh uh who's just
down on their luck okay if you give them
10 bucks right somebody might give them
10 bucks
now that's ten thousand dollar ten
dollars and uh nine ninety nine thousand
ninety nine dollars for for the for the
person watching that person working on
the street how it was very unlikely to
give that you know guy a thousand
dollars let alone fifty thousand dollars
and actually make them equal right
um and uh so so that person me doesn't
actually want equality if if they were
giving thirty thousand forty thousand
dollars you're like wait a second I
earned this money why am I giving it
away that immediately kicks in once it's
beyond just like uh oh I feel sorry for
you here's here's a few coins right yeah
that's why you'll have Cheryl Sandberg
have a press release for giving a
million dollars to the ACLU which is you
know point zero zero zero one percent of
her net worth yeah so so what's what's
but here's what's happening is um what
people are doing with that consciously
or unconsciously is sometimes they're
asked which in guilt sometimes it's a
public donation like that they're buying
status yeah but what happens is Charity
decelerates right that is say the closer
you get to income equality the more that
person Rises the less the money comes
okay which means charity never actually
attains equality you know if that
person's at zero you might give them ten
right but if that person even had ten
thousand or Twenty Thousand if they were
like working class on their feet you
wouldn't you know people wouldn't give
them you know 10 bucks they'd say okay
you know you're on your feet go go right
by contrast with investment uh you know
this is a very famous example there's
many many you know millions of not
famous examples when Peter Thiel
invested in Zuck Zuck was much less
wealthy than him now Zuck is much
wealtier than him but both of them
benefited in the process right yeah
that's like putting ten thousand dollars
into somebody now they're worth a
million dollars at least since the last
week I mean Peter said he's off the
board and then meta has crashed which
we're going to get to because I do want
to get there okay sure point being that
basically with investment you're
actually incentivized to make them
richer than you and with Charity you're
not right charity in for in order for to
continue they have to be poorer than you
they have to be in a dependent role Etc
right so so a huge part of this stuff is
in my view a combination of gaining
status while having a crew of dependents
it's the same process that that was run
overseas in many of these third world
countries to keep people dependent
that's now being run in American cities
now you might you said what what would
be I'd have to change to come back to
California you know I I gave uh again I
think that this is highly implausible
but you know know let's just do it for
the the um mental exercise right
um
I you know someone asked me about this
with like the chips thing
um yeah and and I was like you know
because I I was like You Can't Ban your
way to number one okay this is this
recent thing we said you know and it's
like how to become number one in Tech
okay here's some obvious points
four stem education not math is white
supremacy for technology you know like a
Pro-Tech culture not lol Tech bro right
for skilled immigration not like
multi-hundred day Visa delays for like
basic things you know you can't get like
a B1 or whatever yeah H1B yeah no no but
actually different HIV is like a
permanent work visa yeah V1 it's just
like a visitor Visa right it had itself
there's 100-day delays to attend a
conference you're not even trying to
immigrate to attend a conference is huge
pain right
um Pro wealth creation not abolish
billionaires right pro-civilization not
what's happening in San Francisco right
and I I think unfortunately I mean
civilizations have like a like a
heartbeat you know and in different ways
like China and India and other
civilizations are like on the rise and
like look blue America is just fun in
some fundamental ways on the decline in
some ways there's still actually they've
got something I mean what do I actually
think happens it's possible this is the
somewhat dystopian outcome not someone
very disturbing outcome which is
you know San Francisco actually hasn't
been pushed to the limit of what it
could be if you take it to the Limit you
have a few Engineers coding AI in their
rooms with you know doordash being
delivered and outside a you know sea of
fatherless drug-addicted zombies that
you know these ngos are getting addicted
on syringes like how far can you push
that right San Francisco is like running
the experiment of like you know like
basically turning a previously
functional City into Shanty towns and a
few tech people right I don't think the
tech people are causing that no I think
they managed to survive despite that I
think it's the ngos I think it's the
government the state that is causing
that but the tech people are indirectly
subsidizing it by being present and by
paying they are themselves enabling the
enablers right they're by living in San
Francisco you are voting for more San
Francisco
yeah right yeah no matter what you quote
vote for you're actually enabling it by
actually physically being there and
contributing to it and so if you want
less of it you you you you know it's
only words if you cast some Vote or
something like that truly you know
symbolizing it is going somewhere else
and doing what our ancestors did and
moving you know and and you know whether
it's you think of it as a frontier
whether you think of it as moving in
search of a better life whether you
think of it as voting with your feet or
approaches vote there's many different
ways of thinking about that but really
it is moving on from something that
really has failed partly because it was
so rich you know they they got so rich
that they they could just do anything
and the money would see keep rolling in
they didn't have a connection between
cause and effect now they're finally
seeing it with people going to Miami
that's the only thing that's giving them
some degree of Correction right is that
exit as you say as long as they're the
number four economy in the world to hear
and that's momentum yeah yeah that's it
that's momentum and I think I don't know
we'll see what happens yeah go ahead no
yeah it's going to zero overnight but I
am saying that it's definitely no longer
The crucial thing is
it it no longer has power in a
fundamental sense like Microsoft 2022 is
wealthier than Microsoft 2000 but it's
far less powerful it's no longer a choke
point on the whole tech industry right
and you do not need to come to Silicon
Valley to raise money you don't need to
come there to incorporate a company you
don't need it you know Sand Hill is just
less relevant for example a160 that's
why they've gone full remote they've
gone full cloud like Tech is global it's
decentralized thankfully in a sense
we've decentralized opportunity I mean
that's the flip side of this now if
you're in Manila or you know you're in
um you know the you know South America
uh or the Middle East or the Midwest
you've got as as much uh opportunity as
if you're in the middle of Sand Hill and
that's awesome right so there's a huge
benefit to not having everything
centralized concentrated quote unequal
Etc in California in Silicon Valley I
mean what a risk for the technology
industry to be in the worst governed
City in the worst government state in
the world right relative to its wealth
it's like the worst worst government and
the wealth is what enables that it's
like giving a ton of money to this Heir
who just puts it up their nose right
that's what San Francisco is you know
and yeah we're doing you know we're
giving rebates and gas inflation you
know bonuses uh sending out uh here in
California because we uh obviously have
too much money I mean my favorite
statistic is the nap the NASA budget you
know for all of 2020 is lower than the
Los Angeles Unified School District
budget and you look at how much NASA
does and just just incredible
is just obvious stop throwing more money
at it it's getting people that actually
care about it going to what does it do
another country I mean don't they go to
school year round I mean I get paid a
very handsome salary by the state of
California I'm not complaining I'm a
state employee Gavin Newsom is my
ultimate boss right
oh sure I guess so but the point is you
know uh you know I would be doing this
job even if I didn't get paid or I I
love it so much I love being a scientist
I love working with people uh it doesn't
mean it couldn't be you know infinitely
better and I wonder you know you
mentioned this a lot of what I'm seeing
nowadays is kind of this Nexus around uh
colleges I'm coming to think of you know
ironically my profession is sort of you
know one of the stem causes for for some
of these challenges I mean the
ideologies that come out I mean what
you're explaining in the in the you know
kind of extrapolation of the end of you
know modern history maybe the Fujiyama's
kind of torturing thing uh but but but
more than that is is sort of like what's
next is like is China inevitably going
to become like you know woke San
Francisco if they continue on this is it
like an inevitable dialectic of History
uh but I see all these ideas originate
in the University system and those those
come from you know the the pattern of of
basically the old world I mean the most
you know Humboldt and the and the
institutions of of Germany that educated
the first phds in America uh and now you
know kind of doctor all you know doctors
of Education Etc that set public school
policies and now we have you know like
my kids go to school you know Nine
Months of the Year why is that I mean
like do they not have stuff to do I read
a statistic that actually the biggest
discrepancy between you know
disadvantage economically disadvantaged
kids and non-disadvantaged Kids was
sometimes you know unfortunately uses a
proxy for black and white or minorities
or whatever
um I don't want to get into that but but
the study disaggregates by that anyway
the biggest difference is that the
wealthier kids do something over the
summer in other words they're not idle
for three months during the summer
they're going they're doing something
even if it's going to a water park
they're interacting they're solving
problems they're doing some kind of
thing out of the house
um and then obviously it's best to have
some kind of enrichment program but the
poor kids don't have that and it would
be so obvious like this keeps school
open at 12 months of the year why why
should a a public art teacher they'll be
tenured in the state of California you
know in a school what do they need
tenure for academic freedom are they
doing research that started on The
Cutting Edge I don't even think I need
tenure I should get your opinion about
Academia first of all well so okay so I
mean yeah response a ton I could say in
Academia but we so I'll give you a very
quick version I've talked about this at
length and you know various other
podcasts
but I'll like pasting a link at the end
um sure version is independent
replication over procedure citation
um
essentially what's happened is Academia
has mistaken the form for the substance
the entire infrastructure of NSF and NIH
and universities and journals and so on
is just you know a superstructure on top
of the fundamental I mean it's got a few
different Origins but this I'm just
taking the the stem part of it
um
and all of that is the superstructure on
one person telling another person how to
replicate an experiment
that's actually all that truly matters
if you cannot independently replicate
the experiment it's not science it may
be published in a scientific journal it
may look like we think of it with the
academic affiliations and we have the
form but if the data isn't available if
the protocol isn't available if the
methods are not independently replicable
it's not actually science if you cannot
replicate it's not science that's that
actually kills a huge amount of stuff
which is talked about a science right
yeah and in fact it also allows you to
rank papers you know everyone talks
about citations page
that did here at UCSD by the way my
colleague Jorge yeah and there's
something you know the thing is it's an
interesting proxy variable like you know
not actually what you want to do is you
want to rank
papers are more generally ideas by the
number of replications not the number of
citations Max illustrations has
trillions and trillions of replications
some paper that came out in science or
nature last week you know that purports
to be this is how you know this virus
works or whatever that has like probably
zero replications
and we're not tracking the number of
replications that's way more important
than the number of citations
okay once we do the pushback
respectfully I mean once you get the
Higgs bows on mass it's not like oh we
have to do it 65 trillion times you know
again and again uh that doesn't add
incremental surprise or enter you know
reduce entropy don't know about that and
the reason is because
um for example think about Let me give a
different think about code okay
when you have a
um piece of software you are effectively
it's not simply a paper you are
replicating the results because you're
running it again locally millions of
times and in doing that what do you find
but you'll first of all you'll find it
doesn't work on this platform or that
platform but you'll also start servicing
one in a thousand or one in a million
bugs which uh you know in doing it a few
times you might not have seen them but
you you surface race conditions you know
threads that are competing with each
other rare things that arise under odd
circumstances and by just replicating it
tons of times you find that kind of
stuff right and
um I do think that
if you've got just something which is
true on the base of one expensive
experiment you don't really know how
true it is
it is only if you can just do it over
and over again and you've reduced it not
just to a science but to an engineering
that you can then think of it you know
if it's flaky science in the sense of It
kind of works kind of doesn't it's like
you know you have to get the
instrumentation just so and hold it just
so versus something that's highly robust
then it's not a subroutine that you can
use for something else you know like the
light doesn't just flick on and you can
just assume it's going to work right so
I actually do think much more emphasis
on replication and this is it's not
unique to me of course people talk about
the reproducibility crisis in many areas
but that's like one thing I think is
rotten at the core I think I mean
there's so many so much more of it I
mean basically you asked will China
become like uh you know woke San
Francisco they actually had their opium
period already yeah right our futures
are passed right like it is now
America's time to have its own you know
fentanyl Wars or whatever right
um
and
you know I think part of it is with the
uh you know so some comments on these
um
if you if you've just been born to
number one and you haven't done what it
takes to remain number one people think
being number one is their Birthright and
I wrote this article and it's called
founding versus inheriting you know the
people who are especially running the US
establishment now are like the third or
fifth generation Heirs of a factory that
cranks out widgets and you know they
have the name and they legitimately
inherit it okay they've gone through the
process to do this but they're
completely and capable of changing the
factory to crank out something different
or innovate on it right these are not
people who could organize the US
military from scratch everybody who had
any talent to found has been drained out
of the US establishment into
Tech
and so what that means is you have folks
who are selected adversely selected
they're the folks who are often less
quantitative or they're less good with
budgets or numbers and those are the
folks who remain in the US establishment
with everybody else going into Tech and
then what happens there is it's not the
typical theory of comparative advantage
you know why well it's like the Peter
Principle right you know I can rising to
their level of incompetence and they
happen to master that domain yes it is
that but it's also something where it's
like if if I'm making apples and you're
making oranges fine I can take it or
leave it if you're right if I'm making
Apple computers
and this person is making governance
right that is not a trait I can refuse
right
right so basically comparative advantage
does not work if you're Outsourcing your
governance to others this is a
fundamental you see what I'm saying
right yeah so this is a fundamental
issue where there's no gains from trade
there's huge losses from trade we have
left the government of the United States
the establishment of the United States
to these kleptocratic incompetence and
all the folks who can add I mean you can
you can see this where you know uh a
while back there was this uh clip on uh
I think let me get it right it was uh
Brian Williams and Mara gay okay so
um where they uh
Bloomberg could give a million dollars
per U.S resident and they flashed a
tweet it was such a ludicrous thing
where they flashed a tweet on screen
that said uh you know that Bloomberg
could give every American a million
dollars and they just
it wasn't just that they got it wrong on
screen it was that they didn't have any
sense they couldn't just do basic long
division there's no Sandy chick there
um they really thought of rich people as
being so much richer than they actually
are they uh the entire production staff
for the for this media Outlet didn't
have the most basic contact with reality
and that actually is a it's like a you
know a die test is dye or a smoke test
sometimes you'll take some dye and
you'll kind of put it through a system
and you'll just see it oh yeah like an
exhaust system see if there's a leak or
something excuse there's a leak right so
this is sort of like you're tracking
something through a system you're seeing
these people can't add multiply subtract
or divide okay they have blue check
marks they got blue check marks yeah
they have verbal ability they can act
yeah yeah exactly verbability and their
status so they can act they cannot add
yeah and so it is like Dr Nick you know
in The Simpsons he plays uh you know a
doctor on TV right right and
so for these people to make policy
recommendations policy equals budget
budget involves Division and you know
forget about npv and talking about like
uh you know that's not even like that
advanced math you can't even divide you
know a million bucks
um or you know to divide properly to
figure out that that do you think it's
that it's not appealing like yeah I was
noting that there's basically no
governor no Senator all these hotly
contested you know races and stuff and
backed by this billionaire like there's
not one race in the whole country where
anyone's brought up Science and
Technology they haven't even brought it
up yeah a governor it's insane and and
but and the number of like scientists in
any government around the world I I
think is pitifully low I know there's
like one or two physicists and
um but but I also wanted to ask you you
know when you think about you know
governing of uh of a country or
something like that uh I've done a video
as you know knowledge is not equal to
wisdom and and I've had I've interviewed
14 Nobel Prize winners on this podcast
and I'm always trying to see you know if
a sufficient amount of knowledge can
actually be converted into wisdom and
I'm not I haven't come to any sort of
conclusion about it but I guess the
question that I that I have is you know
who would you want to run a country and
I guess in your case maybe you're saying
you know the people are on it but but I
mean isn't that what kind of Churchill
quote that the people you have to get
the government to deserve and they
deserve to get it good and hard
well so first by the way one thing I
want to say is
um if if you look at the I mentioned
this example of the math errors and so
on look at this other tweet that I
linked there the Lorena Gonzalez one
okay yep she was replying to Mike Solana
who's a you know VC associate at
Founders fund yeah or VP Advantage for
another and she's like serious question
how does it feel to be a billionaire
while promoting companies that leave
workers in poverty do you feel ever feel
bad about the massive quality it's not
every day that a billionaire engages me
on Twitter they just think of
billionaire as being a big number
right this is the same as when Bernie
Sanders like that's where she lives by
the way biology
is where she lives in San Diego yeah no
okay great so you know of course Mike
Solana is like well thank you very much
I don't even know if Mike Selena has a
million dollars like Mike Salon is a
great guy he's a smart guy he works at
FF but he's not Peter Thiel right right
and what you realize is oh these people
don't understand what billion means and
then you realize wait a second of course
you're listening to Bernie and Bernie's
saying Millionaires and billionaires
right A Thousand Times different yeah
exactly it's like seeing meters and
kilometers right right meters and
kilometers like that's NBA players are
so tall they're meters and kilometers
tall right and you know the number of
the ratio of millionaires I mean like
there's like I don't know depending on
how you count it's like uh but it
certainly on the order of five to ten
percent and last I saw I may be wrong on
the stat but it's a non-trivial number
of people if you include house or
whatever that have over a million net
worth in the US whereas billionaires
there's like a few thousand in the world
it's much much different thing correct
so you realize so that's like three
examples like Brian Williams and
marigade that Serena Gonzalez that's
Bernie Sanders they don't actually know
what a billion is like forget everything
else you know we're talking about you
know what Fizz Buzz is
uh no
fizzbuzz is a very basic you know
programming uh question okay which you
ask candidates okay and it's like
um I mean you know let me get there it's
it's basically like print the numbers
from one to a hundred
um and uh for each multiple of three
print Fizz instead of the number and for
each multiple of five print buzz and uh
you know if it's if it's a multiple
three and five print fizzbuzz I think
that's basically
um the the thing right and this is not
this is not like
rocket surgery brain surgery it's not
rocket science right that's right I mean
that's you know for effect uh it is it's
like you know you understand yeah
basically division right you've got a
for Loop right and uh and many people
cannot pass this right like uh did the
test with you know Princeton seniors and
you know if uh factory makes five
widgets in five hours or whatever you
know how many does 100 make at 100 hours
yeah
so the question you're asking of oh why
don't they talk about science and
technology they don't know what a
billion is
she's the same woman that you know what
else she's famous for is our our lovely
Congress assembly woman here oh the one
that said fued Elon Musk yeah and he
said message exactly helped drive 100 in
our company and left yeah that's right
so like basically these folks are
I mean
they
it's it's like
the question of why don't they
understand the implications of
artificial intelligence in VR and
cryptocurrency and you know whatever
that's just so far beyond we're talking
like it's in a different galaxy these
people cannot do fizzbuz like you can't
over us the problem is by the way
they're verbal
and they can act
and so they can give the facade of
competence yeah but if you actually gave
them a basic test of math they would
recoil like garlic this is actually Why
by the way including even a single
equation and anything you're writing
yeah makes that that's it in half right
cuts the readership well actually what
it does it yes that's that's the
conventionalism every equation Cuts your
audience stuff but what it actually does
is it makes a certain kind of very you
know
confident political actor recoil in fear
because it's like having Chinese
characters in the essay they don't
necessarily understand it so like oh
okay you know I I'm kind of right so I
went to Paris once and and I went to the
waiter and I I took you know one year of
of high school French but I was with a
woman an American woman who had lived
there for 30 years and she was only like
40. she spoke like I mean you couldn't
even tell the writer comes up and asks
for our order she wears in French waiter
says it's okay Madame you couldn't speak
American to me I said oh yeah well I
repeat those six of those four questions
like he couldn't it's like okay you want
to play that game we could play that
game you know there's there's no problem
but if you pulled them it's like the old
joke you know like uh on the surface
they're deep but deep down they're
superficial and I think yeah yeah
to get to another level of Competency in
Enfield let alone to you know Master
this it's not hard to hand it out right
he's very difficult human being very
intelligent but this that mean wise not
necessarily so well right so here's the
thing
to give a little bit to these you know
enumerates right
um it is actually the case that
um I may have the Simpsons they have the
Townsend of Elders or whatever and
they're like well we have to get a
Skinner says you know we have to give
the sub a Megalodon megalodons or
whatever you know
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah right so so
um just just like the time we have left
basically it actually is true that in
addition to be able to being able to do
the math you also need the skills of a
political leader and or you know actor
or what have you right or influencer a
better way of thinking about it and so
someone like Elan actually does have
both skills yeah right he can do the
math but he can also convince
and so that's actually what you need is
you can't just say oh you know we wish
that charisma-less Engineers would run
the country you need Charisma
charismatic Engineers right to to run
the country and how do you actually you
know do that others you're not going to
build anything but how do you do that
well they have to be able to found and
how they found well that's the network
state so we come back to that right we
cannot complain you know go ahead yeah
no I was just gonna say in the last last
couple minutes I think yeah persuasion
salesmanship it's a dirty word but
actually it's incredibly important and
to be to have persuasive ability to do
so there's sort of a seductive element
Robert Greene has talked about this um
uh so I know you only have a couple
minutes uh maybe someday we'll get to do
a part two but I just want to comment
one last thing on the the Dark Side of
networks you know I'm always using it to
encourage people to have big families
you know using metcalf's law the the
kind of uh you know benefits of of
having multiple children is that natural
Brian kaplan's book and so on on this
yeah yeah so they'll be friends with
each other and then when you're dead the
parents are dead then at least the kids
relationship will be sustained and also
it's not like you need a new house if
you add a kid but you add on you know
they might double the size of the
network and you know happiness might
scale with the number you know squared
and the cost might scale is and so but
what there's always a dark side right
there's always a node that can go Rogue
or couldn't go bad or you know the news
of Osama bin Laden who is using
Instagram that you know LED them to get
his DNA for whatever there's always some
element of risk in the network and I'm
reminded of another Yiddish kind of
story where there's a rabbi yeah and
he's he's in town and one of his
congruents says some uh evil speech
about him Hebrew we call it La Shahara
evil speech and tell some gossip which
is true it's not a lie it's true about
him whatever it is and uh and then he
feels really bad Yom Kippur comes along
he wants to repent he says for Rabbi
Rabbi how can I make it up to you Rabbi
says okay my my uh my friend uh just get
me a feather pillow gets him a feather
pillow great what's next he goes a cup
of feather pillow open okay great yeah
uh I can do that can I forgive it no no
there's there's one last thing is the
wind is swirling around go pick up all
the feathers what are the risks inherent
in a network State not just the upside
which you've categorized so nicely sure
sure I mean what most people will come
to but we'll still say is oh my God
you're so unrealistic it's never going
to work etc etc and they'll say oh in
particular but people always come back
to uh is
um use of force uh oh you know you
inward Army where's the military you
know you don't have new exploit and uh
you know there's a long and short answer
to that go ahead but no I'm just
laughing because I'm nukes that would be
a good thing and uh nowadays right yeah
yeah well the thing is it's basically
something where they're not actually
they're just sort of reacting at the
surface level on something if you know
the the reason the internet was invented
in part you know like jarpa funded it
for something that is nuclear conflict
right yeah exactly that's right there's
resistance and and we might actually
need to go back to that future where in
the event that Putin or whatever sets
off a nuke and the nuclear taboo is
broken you may want to have governance
structures that are nuke resistant right
and you can't nuke a network how is your
nuke that that actually is something
where everybody you're gonna nuke
billions of people that you don't even
know where they are you need to have an
XY location and they need to be
implicitly concentrate in one physical
location if you're distributed that's
actually something that makes nuclear
weapons less useful right it's only if
you're sessile and fixed to a location
and you have a lot of fixed structures
and so on and so forth and if people
know where your location is right so
um you know there's there's a lot of
things where folks haven't really
thought about what just like we talked
about earlier the the cloud geography
versus lineage geography people have not
thought about what
actually security looks like in an
environment where people are highly
mobile we're capitalist mobile where you
can encrypt things where you can
distribute and decentralize things it's
not to say that Force goes away but
Force looks a lot more like drones than
nukes you know and a lot a lot more like
you know special ops than huge armies
right and it's much more Surgical and
it's tweezers and it's you know scalpels
it's not sledgehammers right and so they
haven't thought about what force looks
like in a network world that's not to
say that that no sledgehammers exist
there's still obviously huge
sledgehammers being deployed in Ukraine
and back and forth but a lot of that is
actually also still Cloud War it's also
Network War you know Ukraine wouldn't be
where it is without being able to wage a
really effective Cloud war against you
know Russia's traditional kind of land
War
um
so I think you know you asked what the
downsides are
um I mean that's one downside is is just
that I think uh
which is not exactly what you're asking
but one downside is folks will try to
map those to the things that they have
already seen without thinking about how
technology has changed things it's a
little bit like cryptocurrency a lot
like cryptocurrency where
um it would you know some people get it
right away and for some people they just
have to kind of see it working for a
while so one downside is you just have
to make it work before people believe it
but that's fine I mean you that the
critical thing is for something like
this you don't have to convince
everybody
you just have to convince enough people
that you can get a small percent only a
small percentage of people for example
move to the US that changed the world
you didn't get the majority of people to
us you didn't even get 10 of the world
to move to you that's only four percent
of the world is in the US and many of
those were born for folks who moved
there right so tiny percentage moving to
the frontier can change everything so in
a sense the quote lack of majority
appeal or what have you you know is
actually is it bad it's actually good in
some ways right so that's that's kind of
my my quick answer in that okay all
right I know you have to go I appreciate
your time and uh maybe uh we'll do a
part two someday maybe in person I ever
get where you are you come back to Long
Island we'll meet up in Ronkonkoma how
about that biology there you go
yeah that's even better East Hampton
take care okay bye-bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you